0 كوبن دا كانت وعود وشيشن القريبه لكنه
اخيرا نعكس الاتجاه هو فتح البر الرئيسي
معهم »
لى حاجه بعد للحجر الصحي لكن السؤال هلا
رغبه الرئيس الصيني في ذلك ام الطره اليك
ربما ياتي الجواب من هنا في اقصى الجنوب
ومن مركز الصناعات التحويليه في البلاد
هذه المقاطعه الاقتصاديه المهمه
22 مليار دولار على مكافحه كورونا فقط
خلال ثلاث سنوات لما يكون المبلغ بسيط اذا
ما قررناه بميزانيه تطوير صناعه الرقائق
الالكترونيه التي ادشنها تحت ادارته وجمعه
20 مليار دولار في عام 2014 والتي تخصصات
كي تنافس واشنطن في هذا المجال
على الساحل الشرقيه وعند مصبي نهر ينقصطي
مثال اخر مدينه شنغهاي مركز الصين المليء
بناتج المحلي يعادل الناتج المحلي لبولندا
في 2021 عام هي الاخرى في السنوات كورونا
في ابريل وما يوم من عام 2021 تصبب
انتشاره الفايروس باغلاق الشامل تضرر على
اثره اكبر ميناء في العالم بحصه تبلغ 20%
من الحلويات العالميه
مبيعته السيارات سجلت اصفارا طوال شهر
ابريل وهي بالمفارقه موطننا اللي مصانع
السيارات كثيره عالميه منها الامريكيه
ورغم ضربه الاقتصاديه الموجعه
او لويه الانفاق على مكافحه الوباء في
منطقه
الرقائق مثل بس امسي واس ام اي سي هي
انفقت المقاطعه قرابه ال 700 مليون دولار
في 2022 رقم تجاوز مخصصات الرعايه الصحيه
العامه بالمناسبات مع كل هذه المعطيات
كانت النتيجه ان الاقتصاد الاكبر في
العالم سجلات تراجع عن قياسيا التراجع
ملحوظه جدا فطلبات تدخل سريعا وهنا جاء
القرار الغاء سياسه صفر ضد التي دفع عنها
الرئيس الصيني كثيره الالغاء على التوقعات
تشير الى انتعاش اقتصادي لا يقل عن خمسه
في المئه خلال العام الحالي لكن المجازفه
كبيره كما تختار الجديده مع بدء عوده
الحياه لطبيعتها واولها احتفال الصينيون
بالعام القمري الجديد وثانيها المتحور
الجديد الذي لا يؤمن بالعطر رغم اعلان
الصيني اليوم التغلب على تفشي كرونا مع
ايام شونيون لكن الغاء صفر كوبد والمتحول
الجديد ابهر العكس 60 الف وفاء بكرونا
خلال خمسه اسابيع اما هناك في الثالث اكبر
مقاطعه كثافه بالسكان تحديدا افيخ نانو
بين كل عشره هناك تسعه اصيبوا نتحدث عن 88
ونصف مليون شخص ولا نعلم كيف هاقصيبه طبعا
لان المتحور الجديد دورنا في ذلك لكنه حتى
الان يكتنفه بعض الغموض لا نعلم ان انه
خليط من متحورين اخرين من متحولات
اوميكرون في الصين متحفظه عن نشر اي
تفاصيل حتى لمنظمه الصحه العالميه التي
تليح عليها بمشاركه معلومات عن المتحور
الاكثر
عبد حتى الان
تحفظ الصين اطلق دول اوروبا وامريكا شركه
البيانات الصحيه البريطانيه تتوقع 36,000
وفاه يوميا بدا من الاسبوع المقبل ولذلك
اشتركت بريطانيا يعرف فرنسا وايطاليا ودول
اخرى اشترطت اجراء اختبارك الدخول
القادمين من اقصى الشرق بكينا اعترضت
وقالت انها تبحث عن حل يبقى الحضاره كما
نبهنا ضروري انا قبل خاصه في هذه المرحله
يبدو ان اجزاء مسلسل كورونا مستمره والوضع
يتطلب استجابه للتحديات القادمه
ايوه
[موسيقى]
ستايل